more disappointing behavior yesterday
coming from America's least profitable
investment our schools an estimated 1
million students took part in
Wednesday's national school walkout
against gun violence they mobilized at
schools from coast to coast demanding
that Congress and state lawmakers do
more to restrict access to guns oh now
you're making demands huh kids what's
next we all have to eat sloppy joes for
lunch every day I'm a grown-up
I eat clean tidy joseph´s frankly I try
to ignore all these protests which is
why I was reassured when I tuned into
Infowars and saw Scott Adams yes
Dilbert cartoonist Scott Adams explain
why these students deserve to be ignored
there are very few people among the
young who are leaving school today who
would actually even claim to having a
good knowledge of the entire gun debate
you know all of the elements of it
enough to really have a you know a
reasoned opinion the people who were
doing the protesting are the dumbest
members of society yes
Scott Adams knows dumb when he sees it
he spent 28 years drawing a guy who
can't iron his dye the Adams made an
excellent point which is that gun
control is a nuanced complex debate and
these kids aren't nearly knowledgeable
enough to know that they don't want to
be shot they're just too dumb to weigh
in that's why you need an expert and
what do experts say when it comes to gun
control
they almost universally push the
narrative that gun control saves lives
which is why we can't trust experts okay
so you can't trust kids and you can't
trust experts cuz kids are too dumb
experts are too elitist so who can you
trust the middle a confident television
personality with
err and a limited frame of reference
just like Laura Ingraham we're talking
about students here and for anyone who
takes the time to look at our academic
standing in the world students need more
academics more classroom time not more
hysterics exactly Laura that's why the
u.s. is trailing in academics the kids
keep walking out to protest every school
shooting so they're never in school
teachers don't have time to catch them
up because the president set them all
off to target practice the bottom line
is true patriots understand that if you
want to protest there's only one right
way a parochial school teachers worked
with the students and put together a
program of a walk in and they went into
the churches and auditoriums and
recognized the victims with with prayer
I really like that
think about that commemorating the loss
remembering the victims prayer offered
as a class to me that makes a lot more
sense than yelling into a microphone in
front of some government building she's
right
yelling into a microphone outside of a
government building never affects
government change take it from me and my
wheelbarrow of parking tickets sure if
you want to raise a stake about
something you could dominate a full day
of cable news coverage with a nationwide
protest or you could quietly whisper
your hopes and dreams into your clothes
palms where only Jesus can hear them